ugh
hey everybody
i had to heat up my cider
oh that hot
that that is that is quite toasty
yes uh which side there it is green
mountain cabaret
that's the stuff
sister tested positive oh for
covert i'm assuming
yeah
yeah
am i getting drink this time
i mean i i will be
having a drink
as i mentioned i have
warm cider here
actually a little bit too hot so i'm
just going to cool it down with a little
bit of water
there we go that that should i should
get it nice and cooled off uh in uh just
a little while
good morrigan or guten morgen
from june from germany how am i doing
i'm okay i
um
about an hour ago got back home from
seeing the eternals
um so i need to shoot my review after uh
after the live stream
uh
it was pretty good honestly i think i
get why it's
divisive but like
i
dug it for the most part
yes i know what you meant to say ms
wicked wolf i'm messing with you
you should recognize it you do it enough
now it's irish irish cider
you have questions i love questions
fire away with questions no spoilers no
no don't worry brodie i'm i'm not i'm
not uh
this is this isn't the review
i try not to spoil things uh during the
live stream that said if doctor who
comes up
that's probably gonna be talked about
pretty openly so there's your warning on
that but no i'm not gonna i'm not gonna
talk
uh specifics about the eternals ship you
some warm cider i would happily do so if
i could be sure it would arrive
as warm as this currently is
did i hear about the star trek kerfuffle
um
i don't
think
so
we'll see
how can i say flex has weak villains
when evil dan is the best we've had in
decades like look here's the thing
especially with uh someone like swarm i
get that the performance is pretty well
done i just i have no investment in
these people and it the
the thing is not going out of its way to
get me invested in them beyond just the
vague idea that oh they're dangerous
yeah so freaking everybody else in these
things
the last movie you watched is now your
life story well then my life story is
eternal so there you go
in my video for series 13 i'm linking to
your video on lily kaden the bbc though
my content seems to have scared off the
entire internet so i also shared it on
facebook like realized youtube
especially at this point
is not
newcomer friendly i i'm not gonna say
it's impossible to break in because i've
seen people come around you know and
completely surpass me in terms of
subscriber numbers but it's hard
the the algorithm and the way it's built
does not favor up and comers
by and large so
is there a specific criteria for tough
like a girl um yes so the uh for folks
who don't know that's the podcast i do
with my partner liz
um so the remit for tough like a girl is
that
it either has to have a female
protagonist
meaning the main character
the
or if it is dealing with a team
that team needs to be more than fifty
percent
uh female and or female identifying
because like obviously i'm not going to
get freaking
stupid about it um
you know like must be biological and
born no
but female identifying for
uh either the main character or if it's
a team at least half of that team so
that's the remit and outside of that uh
there are there isn't a lot of structure
any genre is up for grabs oh captain
omni uh this is my chance to point out
that if you drop me a super chat that is
the one thing aside from being in the
discord which is a patreon perk that
guarantees i will read your comment and
or question i do try and keep up with
the chat but i make no promises so this
is the one guaranteeing plus
you get a heart from me
because i appreciate it very very much
captain omni thank you so much
thoughts on the fact metal is the
fastest growing music genre
huh
was not aware of that
i'm actually very pleased with that
metal head for life see the thing is
like i'm so detached
from the music scene
like
i
i don't remember the last time i like
found a new song that i liked like in
the wild
so
i don't know man my my uh relationship
with music is
is weird i don't even know what counts
as being in and popular anymore so like
for instance i watch um todd in the
shadows uh on youtube and every now and
then like i swear every time he does a
song like a pop
song that
ninety percent of the time i'm like i've
never heard this song before i mean
so that's that's just kind of where i'm
at michael anderson doyle you'll get a
heart thank you for the youtube
membership much appreciated hope you
enjoy the perks
um
does it have to be for kids absolutely
not now due to our own backgrounds a
fair amount of the stuff that we look at
is for kids because uh liz being a
school librarian a lot of the stuff that
she breaks and like being on committees
for this kind of thing um a lot of the
stuff she brings is aimed at middle
grade and that's sort of where her
background is more i tend to bring a bit
more of the
um the action-y uh comic book superhero
kind of stuff to the table but like it's
all up for grabs hell if you really
wanted
you could float us an idea for uh for a
book of 18 plus like we've we did the
first volume of alias which is
definitely not something that uh would
be okay for a kid to read so no the
anything that we review on there does
not have to be family friendly i'm glad
you like the nails i've got i've got god
i've got four of them i need to redo
i've gotten lacks on that yes dharma i
know i uh you use the same
profile picture in most places so i did
i did catch that
uh thoughts on the revelation in once
upon time that swarm and azure are
apparently not the main antagonists
uh in flux
aren't they
who is
like here's the thing i like we got
introduced to that woman in the garden
which i didn't talk about in my review
but the only reason i didn't is because
i don't know what there is to say about
her unless you're gonna be the
speculative type who's trying to figure
out who she really is and i'm not that
kind of person
but
unless you're claiming it's her like
what is the main threat
because the flux doesn't seem to be the
main threat
swarman is your maybe
if it's this other woman then we've just
got a cavalcade of too many freaking
villains especially given that we had a
completely self-contained story or
almost completely self-canadian story
where the centaurs were the villains and
it looks like we're gonna give that with
the weeping angels next time like who
what what is the overall thing about
i'm not sure it has picked one thing
i think it has picked about five things
and doesn't know which it is and i know
people are gonna say to me well wait to
the end and maybe it starts out and
maybe it does but right now it's a mess
and even if it does by the end i will
still say that it was a rough ride
getting there
uh slashy that's an interesting name
thank you very much for the super chat
much appreciated thank you for providing
a great essay that covers why episodic
focus series can still have amazing
storytelling thank you
like i i feel like episodic gets really
unduly slammed it's this idea that it's
unsophisticated
and it doesn't have to be and i think
it's pretty telling that even on things
that are more serialized it's not
uncommon for best episodes to be
something more self-contained i mean to
take doctor who which has been largely
episodic but what is one of the most
beloved episodes of the entire modern
era it's blink which in no way ties into
overarching stories not even
slightly not even as a background
element it is 100 self-contained
episodic can be amazing i think it was
just the standard for so long that
people sort of took it for being
a basic
i guess
my recommendation for tough laker girl
is seconds
by brian lee o'malley
i feel like i might have heard of that
hang on i'm gonna google that real quick
and i feel like i'm gonna recognize the
cover
um give me a second
brian the o'malley here we go
i have i have definitely seen that cover
before
i don't know if that's on the docket
because we've got like a long list of
stuff that we'll get to eventually maybe
if we do the podcast for like 10 years
we only do one episode of a month jeez
captain omni came back again with
another super chat thank you very much
this one
i'd recommend beast in black for a good
recent metal band look up their song cry
out for a hero it's badass catchy and
filled with 80s badassery my
relationship to metal is
fairly light
um the thing is is that like
there's occasional metal songs that i
like i think if i were to pick a genre
that i or a sub genre rather that i lean
toward it's probably folk metal
cause like i like blind guardian
um
actually quite a bit that's about the
most metal band that i have like more
than one album from
um
so my
i'm definitely death metal is not my
thing man i but
i i do like
every now and then i can find a metal
song that has the balance of just
feeling big feeling huge and
almost enveloping you in the sound but
that doesn't feel like it's trying to
crush me
there's a fine line that i walk when it
comes to metal
uh ever seen or have interest in josh
snares and adam martin's videos
overlooking the history of doctor who's
missing episodes and viewing figures
respectively i've seen some of josh
snare stuff
um i haven't checked out any of uh
adam's stuff recently i don't
i i know there are other whovians who do
talk about the viewing figures but i i
the reason i don't talk about the
viewing figures is because i don't
[ __ ] care
so i don't really watch other people
talk about them but adam's a nice guy i
i was on his podcast earlier this year
so like he's he's a good dude i think it
was early this year might have been last
year i don't know i was on um
everybody's dead dave earlier this year
which he's on
anyway star trek was pulled off netflix
two days ago before the premiere of
season four
like
all of star trek or star trek discovery
because star trek discovery isn't on
netflix at all in the us
it's on friggin paramount plus so
are you talking about all star did i say
was i saying star wars i meant star trek
um so
like if we're talking all of star trek
was pulled or just discovery because if
it's discovery that's actually that's
business as usual for me over here
uh recently i saw a rocky little picture
show and many people have said it is a
transmisogynist nightmare made by an
actual turf i don't understand this oh
okay so
there's a bit to unpack there um
people who don't like the rocky horror
picture show who don't just claim that
it's like
gross and depraved or whatever
um they have a tendency to
[Music]
feel that it it
depicts
um
the most visibly queer person that being
frankenfurter as a
um
violent
uh corrupting force and they see that in
and of itself as a negative thing i push
back on that assertion
because um
the
while
there is no question that frankfurter is
the closest thing the thing has to a
villain ultimately i mean maybe riff a
little but
it is at the same time as celebration
the film overall is a celebration of
being weird cause everybody's weird
and like you could argue that frank
corrupts them but like no
if you watch like this is these these
people have this in them they're all at
least a little weird
and so i push back on that
interpretation
that having been said i do understand
where it comes from
as to people who claim that it was made
by a turf so they're referring to
richard o'brien who wrote the original
stage play and plays riffraff in the
movie i have not
checked lately
to see if he has said anything
recent because it was like
um a decade ago
or so
um that he
he said something that basically seemed
to it basically amounted to
um
he didn't view trans women as women
now it was not the
uh combative
hateful
um
language that we
um
are seeing these days especially out of
the uk
and i
don't think he said anything more recent
than that he seems to have decided to
keep his head down
um since then
so
um
it's it
it's one of those cases where
i'm not gonna say that definitively
he isn't
um a turf of some
stripe but i am gonna say that it's been
so long since he said anything like it
and especially given how stirred up the
discourse is right now in the uk the
fact that he isn't
jumping on the train publicly to me says
he at the very least
is not
uh militant about it and you can decide
how much that impacts your ability to
enjoy the rocky horror picture show
um
so i missed a lot of questions that went
by do i still go by nathaniel wayne
these days i only ever hear people call
you vera um i mean i still answer to it
i go by vera with more people more
frequently
um
definitely in terms of an online
presence it's kind of
it made more sense for me over time to
basically narrow it down to vera
primarily as an online footprint
i mean like i still kind of consider the
vera wild digital footprint to be a bit
separate from council of geeks but um
right now really the only thing that
nathaniel wayne is tied to is my novel
um
and the rest of it like even if you if
you look at the end credits to the
videos these days um it now says
presented by vera wilde written directed
and edited by nathaniel wayne so like
i'm giving myself double credits um
but i uh
i don't know it's just i think it's just
been part of my general drift i still
don't consider nathaniel to be a dead
name it's not a name i have a problem
hearing just don't shorten it don't call
me nate don't call me an athen that
that will piss me off so
but that's a pre-existing thing that has
nothing to do with dead name
any things
uh you were wondering what chipmunks
planned for series 13 and he said we
decided to blow up the universe because
the other option was just six
self-contained episodes of people
standing around in rooms
if that's what he actually said and i'm
i'm
like it's not that i'm doubting you it's
just i'm i i am always going to preface
when i have not like sourced this stuff
myself
if that is what he said
that is one of the stupidest things i've
ever heard from a writer
because you're the writer of the show
you could have anything happen
and if you literally can think of
nothing to do
other than people stand around in the
room or the universe explodes
then
you are really bad at your job
you can't think of anything between
those two extremes really
really
and again i'm not saying he necessarily
couldn't think of anything else but if
he said that then he's putting forth a
public image that he could think of
nothing else which is
stupid
i recommend skullduggery pleasant for
tough like a girl
valkyrie kane is the main protagonist
and one i find rather unique in
children's books i've heard of
skullduggery pleasant
like that's it i know nothing else just
the name
i do squats sometimes uh if i think too
if i remember to that's kind of my uh
that's kind of my attitude about uh
exercise in general
to borrow a british phrase if i can be
asked
sorry if i can be arsed
um
do people call me by my last name
not if they want me to answer them
my thoughts on john kent being bi i'm
all for more diversity media as long as
it's written well so i'm both happy that
we're getting a bisexual superman i'm
also worried well yeah anytime there's
there's new um representation we kind of
should be worried because
like here's the thing
i made a video
like oh god
how long ago did the first wonder woman
come out
four years ago
something like that three or four years
ago
um i made a video and i was talking
about um
uh
women-led superhero movies and how there
was all this pressure put on wonder
woman that while the movie was very good
there was
this insane amount of discourse around
it which there was no reason for there
to be except for the fact that it was
the first female-led superhero movie
since freaking catwoman so because there
were so few examples it had to carry so
much more weight and that's kind of
where we're at with representation in
general until representation is so
common as to be unremarkable every time
there is new representation we can't
help but get nervous because if it fails
then that means a higher percentage of
failure just because there's so few
other things to pad the numbers with
yeah i assume you've heard about the
boss of the bbc said the lgbt employees
who brought up concerns regarding that
article
uh
if they said something specific about
them
no i haven't i know the bbc uh stopped
working with the stonewall
initiative
on the
basis
um
that they have to remain neutral which
means they are obligated to provide
alternate viewpoints on the trans issue
it's um
it's worth noting
that they do not consider the
rights of gay people to be a matter for
debate they consider that settled and
not
something that they have to take a
neutral stance on
but they do trans rights
it's um
it's very telling
there's two things that are very telling
the first is that they're going to frame
it as the rights of trans people as
being a matter for debate in the first
place because they wouldn't take that
position on the issue of
do jewish people deserve rights do women
deserve rights do gay people deserve
rights they don't treat it as like
something that we have to show both
sides of but they do with trans people
so it immediately shows what they think
about
trans people in the first place
then the other thing
and i pointed this out on twitter
is that if the only way you can provide
this
other side this alternate viewpoint
is with an article
deceptively sourced from an incredibly
small sample size from an incredibly
biased grouping of people that does not
meet your own
journalistic standards and included
someone who didn't live in the uk who
had a history of sex abuse to fight
despite the fact that the article was
about sex abuse directed at women and
you interviewed a woman who has a
history of sex abuse and on top of that
it contains a flat out still today
contains a flat out confirmed lie
because the article says that a number
of trans women reached out to and that
none of them wanted to speak to the
woman who wrote the article which is a
[ __ ] lie because chelsea poe was not
only said yes she was interviewed she
warned them about lily kade and they did
not include her comments yet the article
still says no trans women responded
which is a lie so they felt that it was
more important
to present something anything to buoy
this alternate view of trans people
that they put forward something that did
not be thrown journalistic standards
contains provable lies
if that's what you have to put up to be
able to put up anything that is
on the other side of this debate i think
that's insanely telling
because this was your opportunity to
present the best case against trans
people and that's what you came up with
i try not to swear on the stream too
much but [ __ ]
bbc news
apparently hallie barry should get her
chance to do another catwoman
i think directing her something i'm like
yeah why not plus i like the catwoman
movie i
i did have to not like front to back but
i did have to re-watch parts of catwoman
last month and
she added insult to injury claiming
queer people need to get used to hearing
views they don't like
yeah yeah i did read that
yeah i did
do you like it when i call you sexy
i don't know
that's fine as long as you're not creepy
about it
sorry you asked that question when i'm
not quite out of the headspace of being
pissed off it's not the best time to ask
me if i like being called sexy
i'm allowed to curse on my own stream i
know but i try not to curse on on this
youtube channel
um
my car's on the twitch stream
a bit
um
beautiful when you're angry thank you
i'm glad somebody thinks so
ah
so
let's see
my 13th doctor opinion is that jody's
first real strong episode is demons of
the punjab i need to rewatch after
series 13 is done i'll probably well
maybe not immediately i don't know at
some point probably next year i am gonna
pick up uh take two doctor who review
again and tackle series 11 because it's
been long enough that it's worth um
revisiting at this point
best thing one could say about catwoman
and batman and robin is it's not batman
v superman
that's a low bar
how should is wb batwoman i have no idea
i haven't watched it
i'm currently working on my first
superhero story if you want to hear it
i'm willing to share
i mean
i would like to say yes but
realistically
if you send it to me i'm never gonna get
to it
like i'm i'm never caught up on my own
stuff
and i would like to be the kind of
supportive person who's like yeah sure
send me your stuff i'll i'll tell you
what i think but like i realistically i
can't
i'm just never going to get to it
when chaminade talked about people
standing in rooms i thought he meant
because of covet
well like that's it that is something
that
it's hard to know
how much um
the shooting restrictions
of covet affected the kind of story he
even tried to tell it does make me
wonder if this is part of why he leaned
on something with so many heavy special
effects so that he could basically green
screen people into situations
um
to try and cover for
the shooting restrictions i don't know
if that's true but it would explain a
little bit
uh oh
charlie
charlie henessian
vaquidano i butchered that i am certain
thank you very much for the super chat
much appreciated do i think doctor who
should explore some eldritch cosmic
lovecraftian horror story lines
um
yes
but carefully so here's my thought on
that um in general yes but first of all
the doctor should never meet cthulhu
that would be really stupid and fan
wanky
um
that having been said
um
i think the aspect of lovecraftian
horror i would like to see come up is i
would like don't overdo this but i would
like the doctor
to not
know what it was they just
encountered i would like that to happen
more often because i think about
something like
impossible planet in the satan pit
where at the end of it
um
you know rose
it's presented like it's the devil or
it's the thing that inspired the idea of
the devil or whatever but rose asked him
you know
what actually was that
and the doctor says i don't know never
did sort that out properly and rose kind
of pushes him on it and he says
i think
we beat it and that's good enough for me
and i kind of want some more instances
where the doctor
can't completely figure out
what it is that he just dealt with what
it wanted why it was doing what it was
doing if it realized it was being
harmful if it cared
and the doctor just doesn't know i'd
like to see that every now and then at
least
have i seen jojo a rabbit i have it's
great i did not intend to get a
membership to council geeks after buying
both
books and solving the twitch stream you
are on a roll
i will say that
uh whenever i hear cthulhu i immediately
think of south park oh god
that but god that episode happened back
when i was still watching south park
that was a while ago
i think one doctor whose story implied
that lovecraft's biggest monster not
cthulhu was the doctor i groaned
dear god no
or like in midnight yes
yes gozer god like seriously
midnight is very lovecraftian
not in the sense of like big tentacled
squid monsters that people tend to think
love crafters about but in terms of we
don't know what we don't know why we
don't know
any we just know something messed up
happened midnight's really love crafty
and in terms of tone and mood yeah
yeah
more please
in your squig game review you noted how
significant it was that none of the
billionaire spectators were women you
singled out women specifically but
didn't elaborate explain
well that just has to do with the fact
that um the richest woman in the world
barely cracks the 50 wealthiest people
on the planet so if you're going to
criticize capitalism it makes a hell of
a lot of sense for it to be all dudes
i was on implying women that women are
somehow better than men and incapable of
that kind of wickedness but if sweet
game is is an indictment of capitalism
which it is then yeah you should
probably target the people who are
actually at the top of the frickin
pyramid as opposed to pretending that
the one percent is more diverse than it
actually is
you saw
i'm not sure i'm gonna i'm not sure i'm
gonna read that comment out loud ms
wicked wolf
i'm debating whether or not i'm gonna
read that comment out loud funniest
moment in catwoman is when francis
conroy said her research into catwoman
myth got her fired because male academia
yeah that would
count catwoman is this weird
bizarre mix
of
contempt for the source material
no idea how to
shoot anything
and
really misplaced and badly executed
attempts at girl power
like it's
it's a trip that movie
after watching catwoman watch swordfish
with halle berry to get the bad taste
out of your mouth
i see i'm not sure if i'd agree with
that
now okay so jb i don't know if the
problem is you or my brain because the
first thing my brain went to is like
yeah the scene where she's topless
that'll take the curse off it i don't
know if that's what you were implying or
if my brain was just being a horny
jerk
so i actually i actually went to visit
my mom on her birthday she's also an
english teacher and when i brought up hp
lovecraft
uh she asked who not kidding
huh
i guess my first question is what grade
level is she an english teacher
and also like it's not uncommon for
unless they're unless they specialize
it's not uncommon for those teachers to
not focus on
genre fiction
horror sci-fi fantasy like things like
tolkien get a pass that's about it
though
hi i just wanted to say thank you for
making my daughter happy as always uh
she's a ds child who is very specific
about what she likes and watches thank
you for all your work oh thank you
natasha
thank you very much
i appreciate that
um
catwoman's better than suicide squad
i would say they're equally bad in
different ways
uh personally
what are my favorite crossovers either
in comics tv or movies um
can i be honest
i'm not a big fan of crossovers
they tend to just be
forgive the term fan wank
like they read like fanfic most of the
time and i just
i don't know i cannot i'm having a hard
time thinking
of a crossover that was good other than
ones that are like
jokes
like the
batman brave and the bold and scooby-doo
like
that was fun because it didn't take
itself seriously
i'm not just
part of the thing with crossovers is
somebody somebody's
entire thing is gonna take a hit because
more often than not you're mashing
together two things that don't naturally
fit together whether it be because of
logistics or tone or style or whatever
so something is going to be morphed to
better fit the um
the tone of the other thing and it's
just a question of which one gets the
shaft
really
just was wondering if you heard of a
podcast called less is morg
well i love the name uh it's an
independent series following the dis
dysfunctional life of a lesbian ghost
and a non-binary ghoul
that would make for a dysfunctional
relationship
what are some of my favorite animated
series um the max gargoyles shiran the
princesses of power
uh gravity falls
batman the anime series
there's a lot of good ones oh
john vinyls thank you very much for the
super chat you get a heart
um why do you think tolkien gets a pass
from academia in a way that other genre
fiction such as lovecraft or samantha
shannon do not um basically because
tolkien himself was a
professor and a history and linguistics
nerd so
um
you know
you can talk about tolkien and talk
about the deep depths of
his understanding and his mastery of
language and creating languages and
creating a history that feels real but
isn't real and bring in all of the
because like he he approached talking
about middle earth as if it was a real
thing and he was an academic writing
about it
so i think that
sort of
odd distancing effect that creates makes
academics more comfortable talking about
him
uh catwoman suicide squad are both
better than batman v superman
maybe
i haven't rewatched batman v superman
other than a little tiny bit because i
had to last month but
yeah someone would have to pay me for
that
does this past our two episode count as
the fugitive doctor having a feature
role or is she still relegated to
support in your book until she's in a
story where she's the only doctor that
appears in it
she is she is a she is a background
feature she is a support character
it's not about her
i'm happy to see more of her
but no this does nothing to change my
opinion of that
i'm not the only one who remembers the
max
dance is happy to answer okay the
the max animated tv show
is one of my favorite complete pieces of
television
i love it i actually think it's a little
bit better than the comic because some
of the specific things that are in the
comic actually work better in motion
than they did on the static page
particularly when it came to contrasting
um the real world with the outback
so like there's
there's a part in the comics where like
the max is running through the street
and it flashes you know that he's
running um on the street and then he's
running in the planes and then he's back
on the street now in the comic it's just
panels changing in animation his run
cycle continues unbroken but the
background changes around him and it
communicates that idea so much more
cleanly and that's just like the easy
example off the top of my head the voice
work is
in that
oh my god the guy the guy who does um
mr gone
holy crap
oh barry stinson i think was his name he
passed away unfortunately
he's one of those voice actors who like
people didn't know that much about him
because he was very private but he was
really good
um thoughts on alan moore as a writer i
haven't read anything i think more
recent than like
mid-2000s from him but
i would say alan moore's a very
thoughtful writer he is not careless he
does what he does on purpose uh whether
or not it works is the matter that's up
for debate but
alan moore is one of those writers who
always interesting at the very least the
oncoming storm thank you very much for
the super chat i appreciate it greatly i
am halfway through the vnas uh and i've
noticed the flux seems to be borrow
ideas from both the vnas and edas
uh like the anchoring of the thread
you're gonna have to
you don't have to do another super chat
to do this um but you're gonna have to
let me know
what vnas and edas are i i bring this up
from time to time i'm real i'm i'm
absolute garbage
with acronyms
and uh and abbreviations for things like
that you have to tell me what they are
because
unless it's something that like i truly
know like
that i truly know it is like i'm not
gonna know what you're referring to it's
it's why i don't use them very much
myself
uh sunday was national pickle day every
day is pickle day for me
um
do i mind if i do a painting of you do i
no
i need more fan art in my life please
please go
go forth go nuts i would love more
people to
draw me or jeez paint me good grief or
whatever in any style however you want
to do it
not safe for work furry i don't care go
nuts
you gotta say i'm kind of glad it's not
just yaz and the doctor in the series
but what i've seen in their interaction
i don't care for it that much
it is oddly combative but like the thing
is what i'm gonna say is i would like to
see that combativeness confronted but
i'm not sure there's gonna be the time
because of everything going on in the
other characters
so
i'm still on the other side of that
opinion would you consider doing an
updated version of your 100 doctor who
episodes to save forever uh
maybe i don't know if it would change
enough to warrant a redo that's the
thing about revisiting lists
specifically
um
how much of it would actually
change
versus the last time i did it if the
answer ultimately is
not a lot
i might just leave it
i've started listening to your fire
escape podcast i'm enjoying quite a bit
no that's great uh that other ted i'm
glad you're liking it i have a lot of
fun with that we're we're winding down
we're in the um
fourth season
that's a fun show
virgin
uh new adventures and the eighth doctor
adventures books that fill the gap
between classic and new who ah
thank you
okay so now let me go back to that
question
so
uh is borrowing from both those like the
anchoring of the threat okay um that
doesn't surprise me too much and i don't
think that's necessarily an indictment
of chibnall because
you know other
i mean heck uh human nature and the
family of blood is an actual adaptation
of a novel that existed um i forget from
what series it was so like i don't have
a problem with that stuff being borrowed
um or repurposed especially considering
that like most fans haven't read that
and haven't been exposed to it it's kind
of the same reason i don't have a
massive problem with certain ideas being
borrowed or repurposed from big finish
either i prefer they not just redo big
finished stories
um that said dalek was great but dalek
was also handled by the same writer who
handled the jubilee the original big
finish
so
just wondering if you support an
animated version of doctor who
and a matrix star wars visions
i mean
morbidly curious
i'd kind of like the
live action series to get on better
footing before we start talking
spin-offs again
um
diamond haagen did a short video
recently about how the look of candyman
and clyde barker's original short story
was probably inspired by colin blake's
doctor
interesting
am i going to finish the mini-series
what you mean flux
yeah of course i am
what do i think of the metacrisis doctor
i'm shocked that
he hasn't been brought back
because i had honestly seriously assumed
that
half the reason to create the metacrisis
doctor and put rose off on a planet with
him was to be able to later bring in
david tennant and billy piper at a later
date and not have to account for the
fact that they've aged so visibly
so the fact that that hasn't happened
yet kind of surprises me
i'm not sure if you think the same way
but when judy whittaker was pretending
to be
a ruth doctor i think she was honestly
really strong in those five minutes uh
she was acting like the fugitive doctor
i'm not sure her acting was actually
that different i just think the um the
intercutting between the two of them
created a little bit of the kuleshov
effect on you
what i remember about return to oz i
remember
a talking chicken i remember sand that
kind of uh disintegrated people i
remember stop action gnome king
and the egg was poisonous
there was a couch with a moose head
that's that's that's about it
new type jb lee
thank you very much
have a heart
uh hello hope you doing hope you doing
fine um question how come kid appeal
characters are hard to execute well
uh because look at the reception of
examples like
don wesley and adrick um
well
i i think there's a number of reasons
why
they're really difficult to do i think
the first and the most fundamental
is that
they're not always necessary
there's this weird assumption and like i
do think it's legitimately weird
that
kids need another kid on hand to be able
to relate to things
and
that's
just not true at all
and like here's here's a good example
from my own childhood
so
i
i loved it's still my favorite movie
ghostbusters
and i loved the cartoon the real
ghostbusters when it came out on disc i
bought the entire set i have the box set
and i watched every episode and there
was one
where they introduced the quote-unquote
junior ghostbusters
now i never saw that episode when i was
a kid but i'm watching it now thinking
you know what
when i was a small child
i wanted to be a ghostbuster
i didn't want to i mean like like them i
didn't want to be
an annoying little tag along with the
ghostbusters
and like people point to things like
robin but robin
and you know being a way for kids to
relate to batman is the exception not
the rule because the vast majority of
the time this stuff just doesn't work
and it super doesn't work when you
introduce it after the thing has gone on
for who knows how long with an absence
of children
so to introduce characters like adrik
like
dawn in a show that has not needed
somebody that young for people to for
younger audiences to relate to
it never ever works
i mean ramen came around pretty quickly
batman was solo for a very short period
of time and it really was just a
different time
that was long enough ago that i don't
think you can even really count that in
the metric anymore
so i think the reason is that nine times
out of ten they don't need to be there
to appeal to kids
and it always feels condescending
and talk down it's like it's talking
down to kids
you wouldn't care about this if we
didn't have a this little snot here like
screw you i would too
you like it if rtd created a new doctor
who spinoff when he becomes the
showrunner no
enough with the spin-up why
why do people think or want spin-offs
when he comes back
why
i don't understand
torchwood had one good season but was
not very good sergeant adventures was
fine but i didn't care about it was
aimed at a demographic that i was not
part of at all that worked just fine
because that was designed as a whole to
appeal to kids and had younger people in
it from the start so in terms of the
conversation i was having earlier but
what why why
why are people
like
it's not you i've seen a ton of people
either suggest or ask like should
should he or he should
bring in
spit spin-offs again like how about we
just find out what the show is going to
be
you know what's great about doctor who
it's insanely malleable and
and can be reshaped
by the nature of regeneration and
things like that so like what what
no
hey
glass is off its bed yeah it's usually
kind of a sign
so far from what i've seen of yes any
arc she
uh she'd have would be a retread of
stuff done better with rose and clara
yes i said clara yeah
kind of
i mean they were kind of doing the she
was trying to behave more like the
doctor thing but they
like
i feel like
chivnall has not committed to any
possible arc that he's set up
for anybody
discord thank you carowind yes um
so i'm gonna check the discord real
quick because this is your reminder that
uh the council of geeks discord is a
thing it is a patreon exclusive perk and
uh there is a channel on there to
guarantee that your question or thought
will be addressed um without having to
do super chat so let me just jump over
there real quick
trying to avoid spoilers and indulging
in hypotheticals as i know it's not your
thing good call so for me this was the
first of the three that really reminded
me okay talk to talk about the new
doctor who episode first of the three
that really reminded me it was made
during the pandemic especially after
episode two which looked great i think
it was the fact that the doctor was so
expositional plus some of the effects
work thoughts yeah i kind of brought
this up in the chat
that i think
i i would not be surprised to learn that
part of the reason this story is written
the way it is and definitely the way
it's shot the way it is had to do with
the covid restrictions again i don't
know that for a fact i'm not going to
give it a pass for that until i know
that's what happened and even then i'm
only going to give so much of a pass
cause you know
right around the problem better
but yeah no i wouldn't be surprised
uh next up with the funding done what do
you
what are you going to look
uh
at for the new corsets for the shows uh
what goes into the thought process for
items used for shows or ideas for video
topic for the other channel okay we go
okay so we got a we got a few things
here so i i ran a gofundme to be able to
sponsor um some new corsets because i
outgrew a lot of mine and some others
frankly just busted um
so in terms of what i'm looking for i'm
going to be focusing on black corsets
because that's what gave out some of my
other courses do still fit but they were
things bought
for very specific looks like i still
have an ivory corset for like a bride
look i sell my green corset that still
fits for poison ivy my red corset for
wonder woman that still fits but those
aren't as all-purpose a black corset is
can go with almost anything it's super
useful and i wear it way more than
anything else which was why it was the
one that wore out
um
and the main thing with buying corsets
is to get flat steel boning
never get plastic and do not settle for
spiral steel
because uh there's there's lots of um
cheap ass courses especially on amazon
that'll say steel boned but if you look
into it it's spiral steel
which is
slightly better than plastic but not
much
flat steel boning that's what you want
really get the job done i'll probably be
going to corset story they do good stuff
and they usually have sales so i'll
probably be able to get more than one
um
what goes
into the thought process for items used
for shows i think that was referring to
burlesque so that's kind of like it
depends on what the number calls for um
because i i usually have a strong theme
that i'm working with or i try to
um or an idea for a video topic on for
the other channel okay so talking about
the vera wild channel
it's basically
uh something that i don't have a way to
to shoehorn a geek angle on
so it doesn't fit the council of geeks
and usually just something that has been
on my mind to talk about sometimes it's
something that happened recently
sometimes it's something i've been
meaning to get to for a while um i i
wish i was getting videos out on that
channel more regularly but
you know life
um couple more
uh hey there and yeah it's true being a
small youtuber is so hard it's so hard
to get somewhere on youtube these days
and my videos just tend to fluctuate
wildly it's annoying yeah that is
unfortunately kind of the nature of the
beast especially at
um
this point in time
because i i've mentioned this before
there was a time when youtube was
buoying smaller channels to meteoric
rises
but
the reason they did that was to build up
the big stars of youtube they have them
now
and they have way less
investment in building up new stars
because they already have huge names and
huge stars on the platform
they aren't necessarily looking to build
new ones so the algorithm favors people
who already have an established base
and i mean like me i'm i still qualify
as a small youtuber you have to hit a
hundred thousand to qualify as a
medium-sized youtuber the fact that i'm
able to do this for my job is frankly
astounding
uh one last one couldn't make it just
hoping you're having a good day oh thank
you yeah it's not too bad
all right i'm back in the chat now oh
there are new uh super chats here we go
thank you very much new type jb lee
speaking of kid appeal characters how
come kitty pride worked well in the
x-men comics she could have been
annoying
uh with being a genius but it didn't
well i mean part of it is to remember at
the time she was introduced
most of the
um x-men characters were
only a few years outside of being
teenagers themselves so she wasn't that
much younger than the rest of them i
mean like wolverine was of indeterminate
age but
you need to remember that team started
out as a basically a teenage team and so
by the time kitty pry joined they were
early 20s maybe she wasn't that much
younger plus the whole thing with
professor x running a school meant you
were getting in regular influx of young
characters which kept it feeling like a
natural thing to happen as opposed to
hey we crowbar the kid in no business
for a kid to be here but we put one in
anyways no it felt like a natural
extension
um john vinyls did another super chat
you get a heart my friend saw lindsay
ellis's love never dies essay in october
and now now i am
now
i'm imagining a version of phantom of
the opera where raul
is a trans woman while deroga is a trans
man
boy that's kind of a deep cut um
because like you're pulling in from one
of her other fans she's done like
i think she's up to three
videos on related to fan of the opera
now
what would your opinion be if chidnal
overexplains andor tries an origin story
of the weeping angels maury being
specified as quantum locked
i will not be surprised i will be
annoyed
i think i'm i'm kind of expecting that
at this point so
like at this point to truly annoy me
chimney would have to do something that
i would think
that i wouldn't think he might do and i
think he might do that while i don't
want to see it
like
he's not going to blindside me with it
if he does it
do i think doctor who could work with
multiple doctors like three in a season
shaking up the format drastically by
having every three episodes be a
different story with a different doctor
no
no i don't um
it's not an uninteresting idea
but um
[Music]
no i really
i really don't think that would work
like
just make a good doctor
just make a solid character
there's no need to
like and the thing is it's super
redundant you'd be changing up the
character but
like
it's not like a more grounded show where
you have 3d where like theoretically
with something that was an earthbound
show to have three different
protagonists like to say on different
sides of the world you could be telling
different stories with each of them in
different settings but doctor who can
already do that
the tardis can go anywhere in time and
space you can already set any episode
wherever whenever you want to tell
whatever kind of story you want
changing the doctor doesn't add that
much more other than dilute the
characters because you're going to get
to know three versions of the doctor
less well than one version that you
would hopefully it's well done know
really well
would i rather be stuck in a room with
jar jar binks bar talk or gergie
none of the above i would go for the
nuclear option at that point can i ask
has anyone else experienced what i'm
calling marvel fatigue like the amount
of shows in marvel content ah funny you
bring that up um
excuse me
that's the next video i'm shooting it's
talking about marvel fatigue so um
tune in on saturday
i only asked about the spin-offs because
rtd said doctor who should be like a
cinematic universe so my new question is
do you i think
rgt will create new spin-offs i think he
wants to i don't think the bbc would
give him a slot to do so
not unless um doctor who's viewing
numbers go up significantly this is the
only context in which i will talk about
the viewing numbers have ever seen
extreme ghostbusters not sure if you've
seen it i'm not sure i ever actually saw
an episode
of it
like i know it existed
i think i've seen the opening credits i
never actually watched it though
once jody's left the show will i
consider doing an updated doctor's
ranking list yes
yes i will i do plan to do that when
she's wrapped it up
um am i still writing new novel or
sequel to dreams of fire i am trying to
get back into writing
um
on a regular basis right now i'm working
on short stuff um just to try and get
back in the habit and then i want to get
back to it is a novel it is not a
follow-up to dreams of fire although i
do have one of those in the works and
that will uh
and that'll be eventually but i didn't
want to do that as my next
thing um because i don't want to
i don't want to create the impression
that i'm going to have like a regular
release of books set in that world
because
i won't live up to it i don't want to
become george rr martin
she said
knowing full well she would never have
that level of popularity but i think you
get my point
um also in episode three bells bell said
about vendor i wonder if he will look
different implying that they could
change appearance
which spark fan theory she is the
uh that she the baby is the doctor like
i'd heard that fan theory i hadn't heard
that as a component of it like
people just look different over time
that's
that's a very common
sentiment like for people who haven't
seen each other in a long time i wonder
if i'll recognize them i wonder if
they'll look different that's a stretch
again i've heard the theory in general
which
so help me if that happens i'm gonna
lose it
my favorite dc animated tv shows are
justice league and unlimited young
justice and legion of superheroes if you
don't know the last one highly
recommended i actually haven't seen
either young justice or legion of
superheroes i haven't gotten around to
them thoughts on tintin my experience
with tintin is very limited really uh
just the one
episode of the show that i got
commissioned to do a year ago
two years ago
whenever that was
have i seen patrick magoons the prisoner
i have it's [ __ ] weird that thing
uh i'm watching this and rescuers down
under at the same time that's a good
movie
that's an underappreciated movie
it's fun
action-packed good music
good villain
it's a good movie
uh oh
i hadn't checked the time gonna have to
wrap it up soon because uh i do have
stuff to do i need to shoot my review
for the uh for eternals
um
and uh
and amongst other things one of my
favorite things about flux are all the
evil videos popping up on youtube he's
good at this and
and he wants his soup
[Laughter]
i'm glad people are having fun with it
uh
do i not like the original rescuers
honestly not especially it's kind of
boring
my fan theory is that since the siberian
created the death particle inside a shot
and since it was inside the doctor for a
minute that the life particle is growing
inside her
okay
i think you are expecting way too many
of these things to come back and
actually pay off
i will bet you money
that we will not see the cyber time
words
and definitely not in the flux i'd be
surprised if we see them again at all
do i think doctor who should hire more
big finish writers i
maybe
maybe
um
all due respect the man not nicholas
briggs
he runs big finish uh as a project uh
and the doctor who stuff there very very
very well i don't actually like the
stuff he's written though so
all right i see people are still asking
questions i gotta stop i gotta stop i
gotta stop i got things to do thank you
so much for tuning in everybody thank
you for coming thank you for listening
to me ramble thank you for your
questions your support your
whatever
um i'll be on twitch tomorrow uh 10 30
a.m new game trying out disco elysium
this time
um taking a rest off of hades no i say
that uh take a rest off of streaming
hades
um
so tune in for that and other than that
a new video on saturday
and um
yeah that's that'll about wrap it up
thanks everybody for
sticking around for listening
be well
be safe
be kind
and remember
that you are beautiful
you are valid
you are loved
you're the council
i'm just running the meetings and until
next time
this council is adjourned